I want to congratulate Andrew yang for
running a good clean campaign but yang
has ended his campaign Andrew yang
deciding yesterday to drop out of the
presidential race
after receiving just 2.8 percent of the
vote in this week's New Hampshire
Democratic primary
Andrew yang said for many months he's
not here just to run a good campaign
he's here to be the nominee and to
defeat Donald Trump and to be President
and we knew months ago that he did not
have a path to that nomination many of
his supporters good people I'm sure
insisting via email and Twitter and
reddit and YouTube and all of those
platforms insisting to me that yang will
be the nominee Iowa will be a catalyst
for growth which will propel him in New
Hampshire which will propel him and you
know you got the idea this is the end of
the road for Andrew yang however sending
a series of tweets yesterday saying I am
so proud of this campaign thank you to
everyone who got us here we'll be back
and retweeting his wife's tweet quoting
him sort of like an inception sort of
thing from his concession speech where
he said being your candidate has been
the privilege of my life this was the
right move and I'm glad that Andrew yang
has done the right thing mathematically
he did not have a shot at this point in
time he's clearing the space I am glad
that Andrew yang ran though he appeared
on the program early once he started
getting more attention he started
ignoring us okay I don't hold it against
him he still ran an issue based campaign
we didn't have to agree about every
policy we didn't have to agree about the
implementation of every single policy
but he ran on the issues and he is gone
now in terms of other people that should
drop out looking at the results from
last night
you've got Tom Steyer who grabbed 3.6
percent of the vote in New Hampshire but
remember Tom Steyer is actually polling
really well in South Carolina because
he's just been pouring money in and
steyr likely is going to get delegates
in South Carolina so I think saiyr can
justify staying in at least until South
Carolina
see what kind of delegates he gets see
what happens then and then decide if he
has enough momentum to keep going into
Super Tuesday or whether it's time to
get out he could pick up enough
delegates in South Carolina to maybe end
up with some negotiating power at the
convention or to get some kind of an
exit endorsement deal from a different
candidate I don't know but he at least
has a path to some delegates a tulsi
gabbard yesterday got three point three
percent of the vote she should get out
remember steyr is viable in South
Carolina based on polling Tulsi is not
polling viable in any primary that I was
able to find not only this Tulsi not
have a path to the nomination I don't
see Tulsi having a path to a single
delegate right now I don't see any point
in her staying in she at least tweeted
yesterday late last night that she's
continuing saying quote my deepest
thanks goes out to all of our incredible
supporters in New Hampshire and across
the country I am so grateful to you all
about to lay my head down here in
Charleston get a few hours sleep and
then continue sharing the message of our
campaign in South Carolina and beyond
she should get out then you have Duval
Patrick who got 0.4 percent yesterday
nice guy our former governor here in
Massachusetts I've interviewed him a few
times even though every time he thinks
my name is Marc I don't hold that
against him but he should get out and
Michael Bennett last night actually
getting out announcing that he is ending
his campaign for president so really a
yang and Bennett already got out steyr
is likely going to get some delegates in
South Carolina so I see him staying in
makes sense Tulsi and Duval should get
out right away let me know what you
think tomorrow we are going to go
through the math that increasingly
points to a contested convention and
here's the really important thing to
understand if you are the Democratic
establishment and your goal is not so
much about we really want Joe to be the
nominee versus we really want Amy to be
the nominee if your goal is just we
don't want it to be Bernie and
probably we don't want it to be Warren
you have an asymmetrical path to victory
it is very similar and I used this
analogy last week if you are in a
football game
and you are up seven points you don't
need to prevent the other team from
scoring you just need to prevent a
touchdown the other team needs a
touchdown in order to win so you have
asymmetrical strategies the offense
needs to get over the goal line and get
a touchdown because they're down seven
the defense can actually play a defense
where you would even allow some gains
and a field goal potentially but you've
got to make damn sure that there isn't a
touchdown that is the asymmetrical
situation right now in terms of the
progressives versus the establishment in
the Democratic primary the as the cap to
my Sharpie flies off if you want to
prevent Bernie from being the nominee
you know that super-delegates get to
vote on the second round at the
convention you merely need to prevent
Bernie from getting enough delegates to
secure the nomination so it doesn't
really matter if the delegates all go to
Biden or Amy or if they split enough
delegates to prevent Bernie from winning
on the first ballot your path is simply
to keep this thing going and keep people
picking up enough delegates that Bernie
doesn't get them all tomorrow we're
gonna look at the math we only have two
primaries so far but so far if the same
trend continues if support does not
consolidate we are rapidly heading
towards a convention in which there
there will likely be a second round of
voting required
so that's on tomorrow's program we'll
have continued coverage of yesterday's
New Hampshire results on our Instagram
page make sure you're following us there
at David Pakman show one of our sponsors
is privacy calm they're giving you $5.00
when you sign up for their completely
free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman I've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm slash Pakman